what's a good horror ending it's scary
sure but it can also be funny
emotionally wrought and so mysterious
that it raises more questions than
answers put simply the best horror film
endings are the ones that stay with you
long after you've left the theater so
much of Rosemary's Baby takes the form
of a paranoia driven thriller that from
a certain perspective you could almost
frame it as a story of a pregnant woman
who has a strange dream one night and
then grows increasingly terrified of the
people around her it could be that
they're only trying to help as some kind
of hormonal imbalance or mental health
issue drives her to think they're all
out to get her that's how much of the
film plays and it's easy to see how
other filmmakers might have leaned into
that even more but Roman Polanski's film
all builds to that ending in which
rosemary discovers it all of her
paranoia has been engineered by a coven
of Satanists who arranged for the devil
himself to impregnate her and that she
has given birth to the Antichrist
the coven's calm celebration as they
stand around the bassinet not to mention
the film's refusal to actually show us a
clear shot of the child only adds to the
dread which culminates in rosemary
accepting that she could indeed perhaps
be a mother to this child father's eyes
The Wicker Man is one of the strangest
horror movies in the history of the
genre
no not that wicker man we're talking of
course about the original 1973 film upon
which the Nicolas Cage led remake was
based the original wicker man is a film
that plays out in many ways like some
kind of dream because most of its
characters seem to be living in an
entirely different reality than the
protagonist sergeant Howie they dance
around and smile and walk dreamily
through life as though nothing is wrong
despite the fact that how he has come to
investigate the alleged disappearance of
one of their own children as the film
moves forward we get the impression that
he's about to shatter all their
illusions then in the film's final
minutes they instead shatter his the
ending of this film is easily and
instantly compelling thanks in part to
the striking visual the titular wicker
man burning against the Setting Sun it's
a haunting image one that works in the
film's favor even now what really makes
the ending work though is how he's
screaming out Bible verses as he's
burning alive while the cultists around
him sing their own song of pagan
celebration it's not the ending you
predict as how he seems to get closer
and closer to the truth even though he's
a bit of a stick-in-the-mud you're still
rooting for him to thwart the human
sacrifices happening on the island then
as the wicker man burns you're left
feeling both horrified and spellbound
1974's black Christmas is one of the
most important precursors to the modern
slasher film genre for a number of
reasons it's got the point-of-view
cinematography the slow ratcheting up of
the body counts the holiday setting the
sorority house and it even has the final
girl in the form of Olivia hussies Jess
where the film departs from many other
final girl narratives is in its haunting
and horrifying closing scene in which
Jess is left alone to rest in her
bedroom while police officers guard the
house from outside the camera then
reveals that no one has bothered to
check the attic where two bodies and the
real killer are still waiting for their
moments ensuring that jess is still in
terrible danger
the cheerful Christmas lights of snowy
landscape juxtaposed with that
persistent ringing phone as the credits
begin to roll are among the most chill
inducing things in the history of
slasher cinema it's common practice in
horror cinema to law the viewer into a
false sense of finality before
unleashing an ending that suddenly and
terrifyingly swerves for one last jump
scare he was done famously in Friday the
13th in the Nightmare on Elm Street as
well as countless other films in the
1980s but even before those films
established that one last scare
philosophy
there was Brian DePalma's carry and it's
final freaky moments when Sue Snell
visits the site of Carrie White's burned
down home we are immediately aware that
something is off thanks to De Palma's
dreamlike construction of the scene
still everything seems peaceful
concluded in calm then well this crap
goes down yikes even though the film
makes it clear that we are indeed
watching a nightmare the fear is still
real it's real because of the masterful
way the sequence is directed but also
because after all we've seen Carrie do
coming back from the dead doesn't
exactly seem so far-fetched
The Shining is a film so pregnant with
symbolism mystique and meaning for fans
nearly four decades after its release
that entire documentaries have been
devoted to decoding its many supposed
hidden messages it's so dense with
possible interpretations and nowhere is
that clearer than its ending when all
the chaos at the Overlook Hotel is died
down the camera zooms in on a 60 year
old photo to reveal the smiling face of
Jack Torrance and everyone leaves the
theater or turns off the TV scratching
their heads is Jack a reincarnation of
another man who came to the Overlook
decades ago is he simply another version
of the same spirit who keeps returning
to this ground is the Overlook
perpetuating a cycle of violence to
sustain itself never has being so
uncertain about a horror films ending
been quite so intellectually satisfying
and we've gotten nearly 40 years of
theories essays and films to prove it
poltergeist is one of those films that
could have easily front-loaded all of
its good ideas into the meaty scares for
the first and second acts of the story
leaving the finale a little too
predictable and a little too stiff after
all the scene of young Carol an
ominously announcing the arrival of
spectral visitors through the TV as
iconic in itself and many ghost movies
might have just coasted on that one
striking image thankfully for all of us
that's not what poltergeist does we can
talk about the clown doll the pool full
of bodies the creatures from beyond and
everything else that comes up during the
final confrontation in the film but what
really makes it all work is the houses
eventual collapse into an extra
dimensional ball of debris in that
moment poltergeist goes from instant
classic to eternal classic the kind of
film will talk about forever then to add
even more brilliance to the crazy finale
we get that TV getting pushed out to the
hotel patio some horror films leave you
with one last scare but this film leaves
you with one last laugh as the whole
audience nods and agreements
Francis Ford Coppola s adaptation of
Dracula was an attempt to bring Bram
Stoker's original novel to the screen in
a way that both utilized lush practical
effects in a memorable way and also paid
tribute to the books themes and operatic
sense of storytelling the result is one
of the most vivid horror films of the
1990s and its ending is nothing short of
beautiful after finally reclaiming his
reincarnated bride in the form of Mina
Dracula attempts to take her back home
to Transylvania only to ultimately be
defeated instead of simply dispatching
the monster though Coppola film lingers
on the love story allowing things to
culminate in a heartbreaking moment in
which Mina sees the tragedy of Dracula
as an eternal man longing for a reunion
with the love of his life its final
moments offer some consolation as we see
that Dracula and his bride seem to have
finally reconnected in the afterlife
after centuries of parts also Dracula's
head gets cut off which is pretty red
[Music]
yeah sure the cabin in the woods might
be all about spoofing horror movie
tropes but it's commentary doesn't land
unless the film is also able to deliver
on the horror goods you can't make a
convincing meta satire unless you've
also got the real elements in which the
satire is based and it's there that the
cabin in the woods really starts to
excel
and it is how we die this is
particularly true of the film's climax
in which all of the horrors of the
underground facility are unleashed at
once it's a wonderfully wicked way to
both show us something scary and also
make fun of horror movie expectations
but then the film goes a step further
with the revelation that this is all a
ritual designed to preserve humanity the
film's final moments in which the
surviving heroes decide to let the human
race be destroyed is both the subversion
of what we expect to happen and a
beautifully engineered final jolt of
horror for much of its runtime that
which seems to be the story of a devout
religious family who begins to see hexes
and demonic influences all around them
when their baby is taken by a wolf the
isolation the Pearson family faces plus
their sense that everything they do is
either God's will or the result of
unclean behaviors could naturally
produce such a paranoid reaction to a
tragedy the witch could have played the
whole film that way with no explicitly
supernatural elements and it still would
have worked
instead the film builds and builds to a
climax in which Thomason finally gives
in to her curiosity and asked if black
Phillip the goats is really something
more what follows is a full-on satanic
embrace complete with the witch's
Sabbath in the woods in Thomasson's
ecstatic rise is a young woman who's
able to finally fully be herself it's a
horror film ending that's both
legitimately frightening and genuinely
celebratory Night of the Living Dead
remains revolutionary for a number of
reasons director George a Romero's 1968
film created the modern zombie genre as
we now know it's reshaped our
expectations for horror cinema and added
a layer of social commentary that was
helped along by the presence of Dwayne
Jones a black leading actor at a time
when that was nearly unheard of as Ben
Ben spends much of the film arguing with
other white characters about the best
course of action to take and then
manages to emerge as the sole survivor
of the battle at the farmhouse over
nights with the Sun rising at last
here's an approaching rescue crew and
stumbles to the window to catch their
attention only for well this to happen
[Music]
yep he's immediately shot in the head
and thrown into a pile of burning
corpses just like another ghoul it's a
shocking twist in the midst of what's
supposed to be a calm resolution
something many brilliant horror films
would take a cue from in the decades
that followed it's also a bold statement
on the cultural climates for
all as will and for all his survival
instincts Ben was dismissed by people
who were supposed to be as saviors and
became another casualty of a society
eating its own the closing credits
featuring the body disposal only make
everything that much more
stomach-turning check out one of our
newest videos right here plus Stephen
Moore looper videos about your favorite
stuff for coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one